porque este cambio de parecer de rusia
rusia digamos que pudo haber engañado a
la comunidad internacional él dijo que
nunca iba que no estaba en sus planes
digamos invadir a ucrania solo incursión
militar y pues estamos viendo todo lo
contrario a lo que ha dicho rusia hasta
el momento porque
buenos dias raúl bueno en principio creo
que corresponde señalar que estamos ante
una agresión inaceptable en contra de un
estado soberano como ucrania que ya
venía duramente golpeado por la pandemia
a nivel humano y económico y por
supuesto por la guerra terrible que
enfrenta en el este de su territorio
desde el año 2014
respecto de tu pregunta me temo que
habida cuenta de la reacción diplomática
poco estratégica de los socios
ucranianos ya entramos a una materia de
sorpresa y desinformación militar de
acuerdo a ciertos cálculos a ciertos
cables de inteligencia el
ejército ruso las fuerzas armadas rusas
están penetrando el país en la zona del
este sabemos que las autoproclamadas
repúblicas de dónetsk y logan's
controlan apenas el 30 por ciento de la
región del donbass si es que el
conflicto y limitarse a esa región pues
los dichos de vladimir putin en el
sentido de que no tenía ningún interés
en invadir ucrania más allá digamos de
este cinturón de
rusohablante es donde según su
argumentación se estaban presentando
actos de maltrato que arriesgaban sus
vidas en ese caso pues su discurso
tendría coherencia ahora bien en el caso
que como señalan otros cables noticiosos
estemos hablando de una invasión mucho
más profunda del territorio ucraniano
algunos analistas están hablando incluso
de que se estaría apuntando a que la
nueva frontera
entre rusia y europa por decirlo de
algún modo sería nada menos que el río
dniéper es decir que quien
pasaría a formar parte de esta zona de
influencia rusa creo que estaríamos
hablando de un acto de agresión militar
al que vladimir putin no se había
referido hasta estos momentos
rodrigo eso digamos que puede ser un
escenario posible a que estaría jugando
en este momento el presidente ruso
vladimir putin ya pues quiero
preguntárselo porque no sé si es
demasiado tarde pero digamos que la vía
diplomática ya sí está completamente
descartada no hay nada sobre la masa
diplomáticamente que se pueda hacer
digamos que putin ya no va a dar marcha
atrás de ninguna forma
correcto aquí también es importante
tomar en cuenta la reacción de los
interlocutores de vladimir putin hemos
visto que la estrategia pública de
presión a través de las redes sociales
liderada por que o bailén no ha dado
resultados tangibles y tampoco la
estrategia aplicada por la unión europea
en este contexto me recuerdo mucho la
experiencia de la república española en
el marco de la guerra civil española
cuando en teoría los aliados de la
república española decían apoyarla pero
al final en el plano de los hechos en el
plano de la defensa militar contribuía
muy poco con su seguridad hemos visto en
este caso que alemania por ejemplo envió
unos cuantos cascos se negó a mandar
dada su dependencia energética de rusia
se negaron a mandar armas letales
cualquier analista militar pensaría que
lo que ucrania necesita y necesitaba
entonces eran sofisticados y sistemas de
defensa antiaérea
este armas antitanque mucho más potentes
y de ser posible incluso tanques pero
los eeuu tampoco enviaron
ese material